papa avait l'habitude de dire et je lui ai donné ma parole
il disait Joey souviens-toi qu'un travail
c'est bien plus qu'un chèque de paie c'est une question de
dignité c'est
ta place dans la communauté
c'est
qui tu es c'est d'être capable de
regarder ton  enfant dans les yeux et dire chérie
ça va aller et le penser
[Musique]
je me souviens que ma douce dame me
regardait après que nous ayons quitté l'hôpital
et disait joey de tout ce
qui t'arrive de terrible
quelque chose de bien viendra si tu  regardez
assez fort pour
qu'elle ait raison
[Musique]
Je me souviens à ce jour à quel point le bégaiement était
déshumanisant et embarrassant
à quel point cela remettait en question dans mon propre
esprit ainsi que
mes capacités
[Musique]
quand Barack et moi grandissions il y
avait  une compréhension implicite en
Amérique
que si vous preniez des responsabilités, vous auriez
une
chance équitable d'avoir une vie meilleure et les valeurs
les valeurs derrière ce marché étaient les
valeurs qui nous ont façonnés tous les deux
et beaucoup d'entre vous
[Musique]
j'étais à l'embauche à Washington  le personnel
j'ai reçu un appel téléphonique ma femme et mes trois
enfants faisaient les courses de Noël un
tracteur a tué ma
femme et ma fille
et ils n'étaient pas sûrs que mes fils
vivraient
donc
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Rires]
c'est une élection extraordinaire  le
peuple américain est prêt je suis
prêt barack est prêt c'est son
heure c'est
notre heure c'est l'heure de l'amérique
euh euh bien qu'elle attende ta mère est
toujours
ta mère est toujours en vie est ton père est passé que
Dieu bénisse son âme
choisissez l'unité plutôt que la division
et devinez ce que nous choisissons la vérité plutôt que les mensonges
[
Musique] je veux juste que vous sachiez que j'avais la permission d'embrasser lonnie
pour
lui obtenir le genre d'audition qu'elle méritait
compte tenu du courage dont elle a fait preuve en nous tendant la main
l'audition qu'elle méritait était une audition
où elle a été respectée
où le ton de l'interrogatoire
n'était pas hostile et insultant
où le fait qu'elle s'est avancée
a été reconnu  comme un acte de courage en
soi
[Musique]
c'est la campagne la plus inhabituelle que je
pense dans l'histoire moderne
en cela mais je commence avec la prémisse
mike que je vais suivre les ordres du doc
non seulement pour moi mais pour le  pays et
euh cela signifie que
je ne vais pas organiser de rassemblements
après des mois à ne rien faire d'
autre que prédire que le virus
disparaîtrait ou peut-être que si vous buviez de l'eau de Javel,
vous pourriez être d'accord,
Trump a simplement abandonné
[Musique]
tu es  le pire président américain ait
jamais eu permettez-
moi de vous dire jill j'ai fait plus
en 47 mois j'ai fait plus que
vous n'avez fait
en 47 ans
le président actuel a masqué
l'obscurité américaine pendant trop longtemps
trop de colère aussi  beaucoup peur trop de
division
ici et maintenant je te donne ma parole
si tu me confie la présidence je
puiserai sur le meilleur d'entre nous
pas le pire je serai un allié de la
lumière
pas des ténèbres